hi I'm Timmy the trashcan and I love
trash they all taste so good instead of
throwing your trash on the floor won't
you please give it to me thank you for
considering your fellow patrons welcome
to the Tim Dylan show everybody we are
resuming regular video in 2020 I don't
know how many times we have to say that
we know that everybody gets very angry
video is coming back regular every week
in 2020 people gonna be there meet
people gotta [ __ ] beat their meat we
get it the it's too windy to shoot
outside and too cold in California so
what we're doing is we're gonna get a
studio we're looking at a few we're
gonna have one twenty twenty it's going
do you think you have a not everyone
whoever you most people but you think of
a few people who is look some people
might be attracted to you and your
brother you for that reason but I'm
saying more like they like what you're
saying and it just getting into a frenzy
jerking off to not that sexually you but
just a feeling you're revoking I would
say that a fair amount of people listen
to the show are such too generous and so
lazy that they just do two things at
once
and they just jerk off and listen to the
show and it's like it one has nothing to
do with the other yeah I imagine a lot
of people that listen to the show just
spend a lot of their life in one
position I think I probably drove off
with him though when a but watching porn
but anyway I've done things like that
where you're like I'm not jerking off to
what's going on but it's just time to
get it out yeah they're gonna ban the
people are talking about banning porn
what there's a discussion booth somebody
on Twitter
nobody really other thing you would
think like it's nobody there's no money
in porn right like someone's making
money because there's gotta be something
there's a billion Billy they would say
it's a billion dollar industry I don't
know I know like lot of its free you
know the big star is they know they had
their version of patreon the webcam [ __ ]
yeah and like you know and you get you
get a pair of that
whatever the soil it's nice but like but
you know that from an article you've
read we had when the couple times right
or paid for like a garment or
interaction even with interesting I
would love to pay for you to have an
interaction only to watch it start only
for you to be like hello I think I could
pull hello I think would be amazing I'm
am I'm very happy with Lucy are you
jasmine but I think it would be
interesting I think she made behind it
100%
yeah me to try to pull a webcam girl
would it be pull away like actually like
baïdir' date a webcam girls are not
paying but first of all it goes without
saying yeah start out pay but then then
woo her but you know so a lot of people
a lot of people start out that is the
fantasy right like that's the that's the
course I was seeing back in the day was
yeah is that like because they make you
think that like you kind of like it
right that were they kind of like think
that one day yeah she's just gonna look
at you go ahead put the money away put
that money away I just want you and
there is there was some documentary I
was watching about a guy who has just
been paying this webcam girl if you know
what it is you could tweet me or
whatever DM me I forget what it was but
he was paying her for like years hmm a
lot of money and then she went spent a
weekend with him and it was [ __ ]
weird for both of them it was like this
is weird and I don't because they were
so used to that digital relationship she
even I think maybe wanted to try to give
it a go well he's like how's school
going oh you know my professors like
anybody I like you I went to college in
this and then had something in common
maybe yeah whatever like it's just yeah
but that's different than like looking
you on tinder you go on great d'azyr gay
tinder is just Grindr there's all
different pointy yeah you going these
dating apps and like you strike up a
rapport but like a fraction of those
actually work well in the date you know
I mean yeah it right it's my
easier the barrier to entry is so much
lower when you're just online right and
the idea that something could work and
then when you're with somebody and
you're in their physical presence it's
much harder especially for prolonged
period of time yeah it's one thing a
weekend is a long period of time that's
insane right so it's like you could go
out to dinner get hammered but a [ __ ]
weekend he should have played it like
hey I'm gonna be in town for the weekend
maybe we'll get dinner not let's go have
a weekend to go by but like see if you
can get something going but the pressure
for a weekend that's crazy yeah but that
so that's interesting I had a girl
yeah like effectively do that I feel
like a first date but then she got
making one buy her groceries what one
was this years ago I was like no but
basically she she I think she was trying
to like I don't think she a good living
situation I'm certain she didn't I think
she I would imagine she had a very sad
living City was sleeping in my bed with
me yeah but she didn't have sex yet oh
come she said she's on her period which
is alright but then but you know
eventually she'd let me jerk off like
next to her and this was one night you
know it was like at night it turned into
a few nights oh so she just really
wanted a place to stay I think so and
the furthest you got was jerking off
next to her yeah well that's romantic
and then she how was she when you were
jerking off next when was she laying
down was she favors laying down next to
me was she looking at you she was like
in yeah she was she was engaged okay um
was she fully clothed
no she had her top off okay and touching
I could touch I could tell you look at
hits that was fair game this was what
night three lived there for six months
no quick shoot a liar hold the phone
yeah this woman was being dishonest
Raymond she had your reasons vibe she
looked at you and she said I'm gonna get
over on him right and I felt that right
away yeah um it feels sketchy right away
and I think it was like does it feel
sketchy right away how do you eat em you
meet her on tinder
tinder and she's like um we were having
a rapport back and forth we actually got
dirty right away I think [ __ ] she might
have initiated I wasn't a guy who go hey
won't see my dick right but you know we
were sending dick pics and stuff back
and forth and then she's like I think of
the school the time whatever and I
basically met up Applebee's and yeah I
guess we were strike it wasn't the best
day but she's like you wanna go watch a
movie at your place I'm like sure which
is odd I mean for her for our first date
which was like we met for like
half-price apps kind of thing it was
yeah we didn't have like a
two-and-a-half-hour she was wowed by the
Half Price happy right I'm saying she
initiated the movie at your place I knew
it was like this seems quick right so I
was like you know I this is the time
when I was running and I was you know
five miles today and I was like in
better shape so you know maybe she just
wants some pipe rhyme maybe not I mean I
could [ __ ] [ __ ] but really I was you
know it's possible I'm not bad looking
guy in that moment yeah and uh okay
raise a flag and then we get back to my
place we watch I think that Joan Rivers
doc oh that piece of work
yeah how many doc yeah and then we end
up she winds up but she slider her
wanting to go to your home is a red flag
Wow like that raised it was very quick
it wasn't like me yeah usually in my
experience maybe if you have a great
jawline great bodies yeah quick but it's
like you know you're hanging out you're
building rapport you know usually we
drink it but not like no one's getting
super drunk we're drinking any kind of
it kind of right and usually a few hours
goes by Rand Paul's got a few people in
there you put her in there it's a
practical joke oops plainer than it's a
joke everything that's happening to joke
and this is gonna be okay and it's okay
and you just say these are your friends
and they help you move and you got a
moving business on the side and then
man and then you explain to her that
it's for her own good that you've
restrained her because people could get
hysterical and she could hurt herself
you just you just don't want her to hurt
herself so I understand that your usual
process and I would stand it usually is
a little more of a yeah you talk of war
no it's just you're having a good time
yeah your vibe I get it I understand it
really was much vibrating talk to
somebody online and they're too good you
know to it girl I'm like oh you're just
trying to [ __ ] you want me to send
you my bank account info right and so
exactly yeah so yeah by me and she's up
like crashing on my bed and me like yeah
I suppose respond to the top off reverie
in [ __ ] that's fine look whatever really
means quick anyway it was soon anyway
right and then I think she left in the
morning and then she like the next day
like you know suppose I went to school
to work whatever was the guy who I hang
out Isaac all right and she came over my
place and she was like God you wanna be
things either you would go supermarket
I'm like all right so we start picking a
few things up to make like you know so
and then she like at one point grant is
really expensive every salad I think she
wanted to salad okay but like she bought
this really just buying it's really
expensive like dressing okay he's like
yogurt base dressing and she's like you
said and that's when you knew well at
that point oh yeah we got those check
out and I basically I think exactly how
I'm sticking with it by was like she'll
go separate yeah separate yeah and she
yeah because I could see she was like
she thought I was gonna buy everything
and she's just picking out her groceries
this is a real moment
yes relationship right you are walking
around a grocery store with her and this
is what where is this would be like
Holbrooke area so you're a stop and shop
or at least a stop a job yeah
so you're at stop and shop with her yeah
she starts padding the wagon yeah with
high-end items right and then you get
now there's no discussion as to who will
pay right and yeah but it seem like
she's it's for more than just one night
it seems like she's gonna take this home
in my head
you should home with her now maybe that
but was it more like would it have just
been for one night
well maybe I wasn't making a ton of
money back then that would be really
careful I was because see they just seem
like a weird move it seems so let me
explain yeah when you're at the cash
register and then and you say separate
how do you decide who's buying what
because you're just you have one why did
I pick that certain things you have like
nothing jingo hey this would be really
good you want to get this it'd be like
she start picking things out right and
like didn't discuss it I'm like this is
day two
yeah and I think I'm saying I mom I can
make this I can make whatever it would
be I figure I was cooking at the time
there's cases these or something I don't
know I mean this is chilly and yes you
tell everybody to think I'm a little bit
of a chef so yeah I mean so basically
all these weird things that she was
picking out in Carrigan I mean now when
you say separate Oh Bob you see what is
Jim Jimmy
she didn't play her hand now she goes
cold you could see that well a little
cold but that's not what ruined that
means that might be the seeds of ruin
those interesting but that didn't maybe
now what ruins it so days go by look I
mean I take in the I hop done in the
next morning and we're like so we booked
at omelets right and then she orders
crepes on the side naked I wasn't making
a lot of money at the time let me ask
you yes you're in ordering an omelet at
IHOP because you're doing a high-protein
thing you don't just say you ain't heard
I'll decide to split pancakes we wasn't
we won't guy our meals just okay and she
was I want to get crepes in the Seidman
okay that's fine like I was bored to me
is more like I was racking up the price
I didn't say that right so it's fine but
she's cute three dollars like seven or
eight dollars right here thing I'm not
gonna begrudge it to her
I'm I'd rather didn't we don't rack up
all these bills more whatever I'm at I'm
at all these bills three days in I'm
just younger based salad dressing crepes
I'm just saying here's the thing she
doesn't need them she doesn't need them
eat the crepe she barely eats like it
maybe have her amma at most right
she may take one bite of the cracker she
look like what does this woman look
that's just a thin woman she's thin a
thin blond woman attractive getting into
her mid-thirties and like used to be
like hotter and now she's a sin blonde
woman and she's in her mid-30s
yeah and does she look worn she wasn't
super warm but she was yeah but it was
on the good side of almost war right she
seen some maybe late nights she claims
she used to run a fashion line and the
Hampton yeah there's a lot of people
make a lot of claims exactly a lot of
what so everything's everything suspect
everything everything my point is so
look she already creams doesn't even eat
them it's like Oh what is that a lot of
them she doesn't even have a fork phone
she might have one fork full maybe okay
to me it just screamed like I want to
see if you'll spend money she's trying
to see what kind of man you are at the
IHOP I guess so she's trying to judge me
by how much crepes and how do you handle
the situation I let it go but it's like
it's in the head it's in my head there
okay and then I'm [ __ ] there we go
Starbucks and weed she gets her coffee
and we go and we paid the bill at IHOP
pay the bill and then we we come back in
my place she leaves for the night I
think there's like a Thursday or Friday
we make plans I guy I love photography
shoot in like you know huntin somewhere
like up north in Long Island that's
Saturday Bruce has to hang out it was a
hangout Sunday that's our plan we're
gonna hang out Sunday I'm busy on
Saturday certifier Friday what we know s
or and so I I guess she even texted me
cuz we took this before North Shore Long
Island we went there no no no cell
signal you can't get a [ __ ] cell
signal not Frost not for Sprint no not
for it never slaves like us slice
[Music]
so I'm out there I'm shooting like
whatever about sweet sweet 16 and
whatever the [ __ ] wedding and I get
she bit like I basically get one of you
out of there
I get all these voicemails from her like
just cursing at me calling me a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] for not like we made plans
and I have to call back like hey sweet
sweetie pie
for enterprise you know it's so good
we're gonna be fine I was just like I
had no reception kind of aggressive
she's kind of an aggressive person we
end up going to a Greek restaurant that
I like on Sunday and she starts ordering
zucchini fries and not eating them again
and telling me about this business she
used to run and that's when you broke
her nose I started like second-guessing
the business stuff like why would high
this fall apart cuz she she pushed with
the zucchini fries and you decided well
all her out for being a fraud yeah and
then she one goes she wanted to go laser
tag I think and how old was she
36 and she wanted to go to laser tag
yeah she was at one point that wanted to
go out with nyle it should sink yeah cuz
she was like she kept on look I want
someone to date me like was that mean
like we have to do things activities and
so uh yeah so she starts we have big you
know screaming match in the car because
I was basically calling her out I start
calling around bout her how I think
you're a fraudulent fashion designer I
don't think you had a business and you
ordered these fry how what if she swears
back at you
she said you fat piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah
that's not you cheap [ __ ] like why you
already zucchini fries why are you
worrying these [ __ ] he's like you've
been married for 10 years and it's day
three yeah what a hell yeah I come see
you got one zucchini fries like why'd
you order a yeah yeah I'm not made of
money
right and yes I base we got back to my
place and she left and she sat in front
of my car at my house for like two hours
I came at one point like we though if
they leave yeah and she's like I'm on
my mother like crying and the guy right
and then do you think she told her
mother she thought like she thought you
were the one she thought you were a good
man I mean I'll be honest she got on the
phone with her mother and she was like
mommy I've met a boy I've met a man
named Raymond and then she had the call
her mother up crying and go he he
wouldn't let me
or eat zucchini fries what she was
telling me how she [ __ ] like she even
taught me the whole time how like her
living situation was kind of weird she
was staying in some room and she was
going back to school Suffolk or whatever
the [ __ ] right and like a landlord was
shitty
like you know it felt like a scam in
hindsight it's like I'm saying like
maybe I was being a little cheap right
maybe a little skin flap like but
dividing the vibe was gotta protect your
see I don't like me I'd rather not get
laid and be used and that's where we get
back to porn yeah is as negative as porn
can be and how it can lead to alienation
is it any worse than what happened with
you and that woman
what both have been better staying at
home and having the cyber experience was
really good drove up the porn for at
that point I was really great loads yeah
I you how I just charged it up like
stretch it out happy medium between
people saying we should I have the
government force morality yeah and
recognizing that yet OD'ing on porn is
not good excessive consumption of
pornography it has negative effect it's
also like it is like I'm not using I
probably watch too much porn for years
and uh they they say like oh it [ __ ]
you all being a stimulated I'm a healthy
loving relationship it's very sexual
we're very sexual right so I love the
long term effects were as bad as they
make them out to be right the best way
to live one of the guys that I used to
watch our porn went to Iraq and had his
legs blown off they start doing porn
again I don't know no no but I mean it's
just an interesting way it's an
interesting life story sure was it was
he not was the only amateur porn no he's
your website he was like official dude
and he went to Iraq like to be a soldier
he was a soldier
and then he just you know is he's lost
his legs in the war so I mean this you
know I don't know I mean support the
troops but not you know I mean so the
idea of him no I mean I didn't I meant
paying for that stuff I'm not stupid
enough to fall for that
I don't me pay I'm Emily pay like like
I'm like point
hey wall I subscribe to like bang but
the bank brothers verbal bands like look
now it's a little easier cuz I've never
watched porn now I watch but not knowing
you're as much but like you can get full
length like high quality stuff free but
like back then is a little more like you
sound like a guy telling like this
nephew at Christmas you can get full and
high quality stuff free you don't need
to spend any money you don't know how
good you kids have it I just have to pay
money well I would just subscribe to
bang box you don't have to be a
subscriber well things like that at that
point it was a little more I mean if
you're really savvy sure there's one
more of a hassle to like unless you
wanted to watch four-minute clip I want
even though I know it's fake I know it's
like an actually a you know a job
interview it turns at the [ __ ] but I
still like the story I still like it
yeah these are the fantasy or whatever I
think yeah I was just performing at
Bridgeport Connecticut and I think
what's funny about some of these moral
questions is they are luxury questions
to debate just the idea of like you know
you know people debating like you know
what a drag queens story our at
libraries or whatever right you know
which is inflamed people like I mean
it's like to me I'm like it's people and
wacky costumes reading the kid I don't
you know it doesn't seem to boil in the
library yeah it's like that's the thing
that every but that's a new cultural
issue that's like driving everyone
insane is like drag queens reading the
kids I'm not making a verdict here yeah
but doesn't it seem weird that like for
all the appropriation talk and all that
and like and the self eating left kind
of thing yeah that like no-one's like
you would think the trans people would
have gone after the drag queens by now
and go well you know and like I'm sure
there's no friction
I'm sure they will I don't know I I tend
to think that it's big
drag queens should not be reading to
kids not because they're inherently
degenerate but just because it's [ __ ]
boring and like yeah you should be doing
other stuff that's funner and things
forced and weird it seems forced in why
we're like it's like why have a
dominatrix or have ugh
we shouldn't there's nothing wrong with
that either like exactly where we at
dominatrix no I'd be weird if a
dominatrix had a reading program in
school my god the idea of a drag queen
outside of the drink cuz I think what
drag queens they don't really live like
that right do something new I think some
of them don't I think what bothers
people but I do live like that aren't
you like basically trains that is that
more of the term because drag queen
terms doesn't matter get my point with
drag queens is like it's a performance
thing and it'll tradition we take it out
of that realm but you put into a
different realm it's weird like well
their realm is whatever they want it to
be I mean their host shows on television
there they're there it's not just
dragging yeah yeah but it's not just a
nightclub I mean I think drag queens are
people that are exist in the world like
anyway now yeah a lot of them do not
choose to live their whole life and drag
but the drag economy is huge I mean
people are into it people go to the show
I mean this shows you very well there's
a lot of what I've been to a drag show
it's very nice well yeah I mean the the
it supposed used to be very funny and I
said on the Shankill episode of like now
what's funny is like they're making drag
queens in a moralistic is insane but the
idea is that it's sexualizing the this
drag queen story our sexualizes kids i
don't know if it does or not i I will
say this it seems like it is forced yeah
it does seem like there's an agenda and
it does seem like I will say the drag
isn't inherently sexual it's more to me
it seems like more of like costumes like
does anyone want to [ __ ] a drag queen I
don't know maybe alright it's like a
goofy of course and that's a problem if
you don't go so far it's go get
sexualizing children like because then
you have to like the real legitimate
whoa no we're not like but the real
thing is more like I don't want your
explaining this to my five-year-old kids
it's just complicated
complicated yeah I'm annoying it's not
because like I think you're doing wrong
with you yeah but maybe sure but he's
also like it's just like they'll figure
it out in time but it's a little young
dog even like yeah I'm not a guy that
has a strong opinion either way other
than I does seem forced to me it seems
weird I've been heavily critical of the
idea that we that that young
prepubescent or even pubescent children
should transition with the help of
doctors and hormones I've said that that
is I think tantamount to child abuse in
the sense that you're taking a very
young child and you know enabling them
to make decisions that will affect the
rest of their life they may not they may
not want those then we have a more
permissible social structure yeah yeah
they can study it's like 15 years and
see how it turn maybe 15 years ago
look it really is we can really say that
99% of these people never change their
mind you go maybe I should be allowed
here like but like it really is kind of
like it it seems at this point jumping
the gun
show me the gun and I also think that a
lot of the people that supposedly would
have a lot of the people that don't
transition turn out to just be gay like
you know what I mean now I am so I have
always said that I don't think giving
hormones to children I think that's
wrong and I you know the the you know
but again if the kid wants to dress up
like well it's fine I don't care what
you know Lizzie if you're a parent and
you know I don't think stifling your
child's expression what is the right way
to go I think that only will make things
more difficult later on in their life I
just don't think that you should be
giving them hormones this is things like
look should we have started to make this
more acceptable years ago sure but that
being said we haven't and like let's not
just rush to like well is the same thing
with like you know with the whole trends
in fighting and sports like yeah maybe
eventually can't figure this out maybe
when they transition earlier people it
won't have the same level of
testosterone it won't be is uneven
mium he looked like give it time and for
now it's like maybe yeah maybe some
people just get screwed over and can't
do MMA professor too much right now
doesn't make sense yeah and I think the
problems you're seeing a real backlash
against gay people yeah and trans people
because you have a very politically
active wing of whatever you want to call
the LGBT community that is redefining so
many things at once right gender biology
yeah the I you know who can play what
sports and compete against who
it's it's really this much change at
this pace people are becoming very
uncomfortable with it and the whole
thing is they're like you know what's
interesting is a lot of the dudes and I
meet or I'll talk to you and go out with
our guys that either are not out of the
closet or they're just they're there
they're out to a few people but they
don't they're not public at that public
about it right some of it is because
maybe there's more fluidity in sexuality
but I think some of it is like you're
like well I don't want to make this my
whole identity because I don't I don't
then I'm forced to be in this position
where I have to co-sign write all of
these other things that I don't agree
with that are being shoved down
everybody's throat what's like the women
thing well the women in media kind of
thing yeah cuz like look you had Ridley
an alien you had me George bitchin fit w
you have a certain amount of like female
like you know protagonist is a cup of
Sarah Connor in Terminator I love it
this will have nothing to do with the
carn't against it but it's when you
start like when you start to try to
we're gonna we're gonna make lady
Ghostbusters we're gonna make you know
the for like Star Wars is really some of
this adventure stuff
it's never good like my point is it's
never the people who are like making it
a point to like get this representation
it first of all they do that regular
people their people in power who are
like you have an agenda and what they
what they force is never really
reflected by like the women never seem
to when they really talk to him don't
seem to like it I think it's probably I
can't speak for you know the gay
community yeah but I think a lot of this
stuff isn't representative
dreams is like no the stuff you forced
nobody wants this nobody nobody this is
a small group of people who are pushing
a lot of this stuff they're not people
you you rarely bump into them right
they're not people they're people that
occupy positions of power and feel that
pushing this narrative and this agenda
is a way for them to solidify their
power yeah that is what it comes down
sure and there should be plenty more
representation across the board but
today's shocking to me that there's not
more athletes that have come out of the
closet
there are not more actors that have come
out of the closet and I know behind the
scenes that there's a lot of people that
identify as either gay or bisexual that
are not coming at the closet one of the
reasons is because I think there's such
there's such a politicized identity
there's a lot of gay people just I just
want to be a human being right and
there's such a politicized identity to
it now where they're like well wait a
minute why am I now have to be for third
trimester abortion right let me look
with you the Kevin Spacey when they came
out yeah I mean this is a man who lived
his life helping children make you know
where what what do you think it's a good
it's an interesting question I was by I
was in so I was in Bridgeport my point
about these whole luck these luxury
things I'm in Bridgeport Bridgeport
Connecticut is a sacrifice zone it is
one in 43 percent chance of being a
victim of property crime one in a
hundred and twelve or something percent
chance of being a victim of a violent
crime
yes it's been it's like an abandoned
seem like a what you call a slum or this
seemed like it's a suburb is just
rotting away whatever war it's worse
than a sloppy it's the next step it's
it's basically you have a an urban area
a city center that has been pretty much
abandoned but all of the buildings it
says available everywhere and then you
see you know there's a couple of
crackheads walking around to set the
other thing but it's desolate right it's
abandoned and I was talking to my
friend's father and my friend's father
said that you know Sikorsky helicopters
is
the biggest employer in that whole area
of Connecticut they employ like I think
they have one facility that employs
8,000 people and then they have another
facility that employs around 2,500 and
then a lot of the feeder companies that
make the parts for Sikorsky helicopters
and he said to me he goes listen he goes
Bridgeport has been bad for 30 years
because a lot of those factories moved
down south but he goes the reality is if
Sikorsky helicopter leaves this entire
area becomes like a little Detroit well
he goes we have massive problems you
know it's amazing to me how many areas
are reliant on one or two corporations
and that if they go away or if they
automate even half their jobs you're
looking at serious economic ones like
half of Upstate isn't it yeah most of it
yeah yeah just like the probably
Bridgeport was never anywhere big as big
as Detroit right but like but I think
what happened to a live upstate a lot of
probably the Midwest - I mean Detroit's
remarkable just how big it is now
widespread I think a lot of this
country's already gone through a while
you know those scenarios 100% and that's
when you start looking at like wow a lot
of these you know whether we're talking
about morality which certainly listen
the those those conversations have a
place but it's so funny to me that down
the road we might be like Rojo remember
when things were good right we're
arguing about drag queens and Eddie
reading in libraries like it's crazy
that the only can of it really talking
about yeah yeah unless he's a goof
he's the only guy that seems to be like
guys the problems are so deep yeah and
they're not necessarily given easily to
political solutions right and even his
solution it's like that was all the
month it's like this yeah I'm not even
like it's a week I know that's like if
he's right that ain't gonna work
properly brains probably not gonna work
but what he is doing is is he's at least
yeah here's the problem
one thing wait wait this beard thing I
suppose they will be driver in a way
here because I don't know how bad ruber
is doing like how they keep losing money
am I gonna spend 40 million dollars a
quarter on R&D it's like you know and
probably gonna make it like self-driving
cars worsley yeah yeah where is that
where is that 400
million going be I mean researching you
yeah what are you searching where people
get drunk and need boobers yeah how it's
like and like a certain point and he
like it he's a guy in his 60s and like
I'm the one saying like you know he
should be in my shoes but I'm saying
like at certain point you know me I have
am a free market ish kind of background
I'm very and per se but like bombs like
I'm saying like why not good-looking
enough to be a Marxist or a fascist
there enough that's the reality but a
certain point like why can't we just
outlaw certain technology if it's that
disparate if it's that disruptive to the
public good so to the general good that
like what cuz truck drivers like we're
gonna why that why are we gonna allow
the entire industry people who are the
most vulnerable why can we not legislate
progress or the pace progress pretty
much your question I mean look will it's
not we have a free market anyway we've
gone with the only time we be err on the
side of the free market is when we look
what is the arguments you're gonna be
used you're gonna say if we legislate
the pace of progress in one industry
yeah you could have unintended
consequences in other industries things
like health care where I'm just telling
you this argument sort of thing and
they're gonna say hey Burke can't
automate their cars then how are we
gonna get this vaccine to you when you
need it I mean these are gonna be my
responses can you at least take your
dick as a kid before you say that right
what is that they'll be making that
point on the honor on an altar on an
altar during a black mass you know they
take their masks off you're like here's
the point do you have any idea the
percentage of money that this health
care system pumps at R&D
speaking of sacrificial altars but I
went to New Haven I walked her in Yale
I'd never been to Yale unless I've you
ever been to yeah what do you think okay
the point is first of all is a master
there I wanna go it was like Good Will
Hunting guys really an idiot
get out who let you in here what will
you write letters
I've been cleaning the school for a long
time and then they're like alright let
him write that you just start writing in
Selma the liberation of women decades
back is not what I wanted you did so bad
to be there because I wanted you to see
I wanted to film you outside the
skullenbones tomb me and you I want
somebody to film us yelling you think
you're better than me there was
something to mean it was so funny about
that idea if you better sector brothers
you may miss the Rothschild Rockefeller
here's the thing I know there's this
thing I don't think that anyone gets
called like it's not like a bush george
w bush gets a phone call and they
arrange to have us removed but you think
there's like look a lot of them become
presidents or sanders by the way has to
like remove up from what that's a great
guy
remove us from what i know my plan to
broadcast from somewhere outside of
Tampa do you're like oh yeah but my
voice security look a lot even become
presidents and shorten presidents of
Goldman Sachs or whatever
presidents have something yeah and
there's gotta be at least a couple who
hang around campus though well so I
looked up so the the the the Bonesmen
that there was a price you know I think
it was around 2000 and I don't know but
Facebook made a lot of photo albums
public that were once private so then
there was just this photo album of all
these bondsman who supposedly bones kids
both kids well you know Yale Bonesmen
we're gonna haul yeah but you know not
older people like you know new inductees
or whatever and they you know there's
this upstate New York is this island
Deer Island which is a private
skullenbones I'll that's kind of a dump
right but these kids and probably older
members are the thing they all go there
together
the thing about skull and bulges I
actually think you know it from having
wrists Baker on the show and all that
stuff it is just a fraternity of the
wealthiest people in the world
bro that being said I'm
or within it there are constellations of
power sure yeah but also that ain't
nothing for charity of the wealthiest
kids in the world yes and they are
laying in coffin trick and fake blood
and there's mock sacrifice I'm always in
this thing Bohemian Grove mock sacrifice
risk almost mock sacrifice why are we
doing all these mock sacrifice yeah you
know what I mean thing yeah well here's
my example I look at menus of
restaurants I'm not gonna eat it all the
time and I have like I have a mock meal
right I look at what I'd order but I'm
fat right you know what I mean yeah as I
really eat a lot of the time right so
the idea that you're like just mock it's
always a mock stuff those a metaphor for
everything how many other fraternities
are there you probably scrolling key
wolf's head there's a lot of elite I'll
try let's just say ten elite fraternity
yes any one of them yes you're almost
control in the world look you do it's a
few you're maneuvering I'll tell you
what your life friends I know from
college I don't think I remember one he
runs a print route from Martin we're not
which I have lobster shop from Sables by
the way I wanted you to bring potato
rolls I've great lobster salad
phenomenal but but that point is like so
the idea that like one step more now
we're in the most weird elite one and we
do weird [ __ ] yeah so you can cause like
of course this is like you're already
rich kids who have my influence right
it's just like skullenbones isn't the
Nexus of power it's just a Facebook
group of next yeah it's just their
social media back then yeah it's just
what it is and it's just the way it's
the entrance point right into a world so
I looked at these cuz I looked at the
pictures of these kids and they just
look like college kids my diverse first
college kids women everything on the
site so I started looking up some of
them in their LinkedIn's and everything
it's kind of funny like some of them are
like s J Dobbs
I think these skull and bones sjw is
great right I like that that's actually
a thing yeah like the kids are like I'm
an activist but I you know what I mean
they truly believes they're making the
world better I mean what was Damon
rocker who is David Rockefellers
grandson
they're global warm act
who is it yeah I don't know if his name
but the point the ruler watch how kids
are like yeah I have some [ __ ] there if
I can try and save the world right right
yes stomping around a dirty white
converse shoes it's like we need to
start doing better so they don't remove
us from power yes like no Grandpa's able
to like [ __ ] strip-mine Africa I just
love it's like how do they square the
how do they make it all work in their
head
look best-case yeah I don't think they
fully believe it but no because they
look someone has to make it better and
they have their hands on the on the
wheels of power or close to it and it's
like we need to bring this the the wheel
the the mechanisms of power into the
21st century of equality right an
anti-slavery race is right you know we
need to make the world better weeds
we're gonna be stable
we can't wear this [ __ ] it's like chaos
cries I want me and you to do a show at
skullenbones where we get up there in
the dark because we can't see anyone in
the group now III want to pitch this to
yell I'm dead serious now of course this
is not gonna happen because they employ
several levels of people to make sure
nothing like this ever happened that
ever ever ever
but the idea go with me for a second job
skis not funny the idea that me and you
come out on the stage okay we have like
top hats take go with this they the kids
the Bonesmen they're all in whatever
they're in their coffins in their seats
in the dark we come out on stage and we
do our bit we do our our you know we
covered the Long Island diner the
Luciferian elite you know you go on
about Kermit Roosevelt for a while
it's we do our whole hour and then we
just get out of it maybe we have a dance
routine at the end or you know something
fun for everyone and we can be
compensated but I would do it pro bono I
would just do it for the experience of
doing it I just don't think that they
it's sad Raymond that they don't have
the sense
humor that's what saddens me I think you
have these snowflakes and skullenbones
who's very popular right now in comedy
like who's like Kevin Hart I would say
him I mean like you know fluffy what was
a big people really like rah Amy Schumer
thing get any of them yeah but they
don't even what from their perspective
but yeah people like bears are wild it's
funny Kevin Hart wouldn't waste his time
there they can't they can't afford him
the point is that thanks again for him
uh they could but there they wouldn't
and he's one of those dudes who like
doesn't he's like my point he's like our
act is for them sure I think act is not
but isn't part of their thing of course
it's not but isn't part of their thing
they don't care about the or whatever
the art is they just want them to see we
had Kevin Hart come down but we weren't
talking about any of it anyway this is
my par do you see my point now okay it's
all the same when you can't talk right
there's a soft piano every thing feels
good in the dark there's soft piano me
and you come out we're doing something
it's pretty choreographed we're for
bigger bet we're pretty light on our
feet yeah quite Jackie Gleason but we're
pretty damn good yeah oh you know we're
doing a little thing a little soft-shoe
nobody likes that nobody thinks that's
funny they might like it I'm just
putting that into the world because a
lot of people listen to this show and
maybe maybe you're maybe you're in
skullenbones and you're afraid to reach
out to us but don't be we have a picture
of Stalin up on them on the projector
yes you got a friend we do a hope you
know it's like Stalin Genghis Khan is
like we are this is what I'm just a [ __ ]
it's a fun romp that's all yeah and then
I think we should I'm just saying look
we can't broach this idea as I know
somebody that knows someone who works at
yeah I have floated this idea and the
response I got was no you have a manager
you have an agent but we've broached the
idea of I mean
we brochette you in the pass of me for
certain purposes being your you know
your your at you your agent or I will
negotiate with you yes I will get them
on the phone I will make threats well
yeah yeah I will husband listen to this
this was not a serious the regulation
but there would be nothing funnier than
having you negotiate listen here's a
reality listen the money you need to
understand what we're gonna deliver two
words Murray Rothbard
you've never seen a show like we're
gonna Reserve Bank this is like the
circus well you could hit the animals
when things ran efficiently you wanna
stick things in us yeah
okay it's all game I mean there's
something I like about the idea of you
know I always wanted to be an elite
Raymond I've always wanted to be in the
league but I was fat and I came from
Long Island do you want it too much I
got you gotta take the take a cue from
me you hungry I think you're full of the
hello.c because you you present as
homeless right and disturbed so did you
ever see a movie with Joe Pesci where's
a homeless guy Harvard not the five I'm
going for no but I did see the Irishman
I want to kill myself so the reality is
I'm just saying these Skull and Bones
guys what do you think it's like to be
in an institute tapped Scullin ball I
mean I went to Nassau Community College
what's interesting is like so Bush's kid
gets in Terry's kid gets in which the
daughter doesn't want to be in she got
tapped she said now they have La females
they have females now yeah well here's
that's that's the interesting thing
there's a couple levels here cuz a it's
like there is that elite crop how what
is the level like what is the more
marginal like who are the guys who like
earn their way into skullenbones um look
guys you stole Geronimo's skull like
Prescott Bush and things like that with
your first the first it was I think he's
one of the first classes of people we
don't say no my point is all legacy or
some of these people know people are in
their way they're a big that are looked
at as leaders think oh this person's
gonna be a leader for right reason so I
like those guys interested also like is
it
the same the same way like when you know
about like you know the navy suit like
your Navy SEALs are called Navy's like
DEVGRU and there's a SEAL Team six buts
not really SEAL Team 6 anymore
they changed the thing so is Skull and
Bones even the thing anymore
like its gender butchers going I don't
wanna be a part of this is it is there
something else is there just like you
know bomblets clothes social club or
whatever that's hey your bondsman I'm
actually bottom of social I'm just
saying the idea of being an elite from
the secret society just a div gulping it
yell going to yell I think it's probably
the thing all right pranks or elites I
think it's great George yeah I went yeah
I think George Bush Senior the first you
know Prescott Bush or the Walker Bush
whatever who cares the one who's in the
CIA director you know first president
Bush I think he because his role in the
CIA and probably killing Kennedy get
Nixon like he enjoyed the work but most
these guys you look at like Hitler you
look at like Stalin Stalin was a
criminal Hitler reserved whatever the
[ __ ] he was like a [ __ ] soldier
returning [ __ ] degenerate yeah let's
just order that quote Stalin's criminal
Hitler as a soldier let's just that's
gonna be great for the new podcast app
transcription service no I'm thinking
look at the general for this yeah yeah
the point is these incoming elites but
the people who really want to go go
crazy transforming the world in their
own image usually don't seem to come
from these circles so it's probably it
doesn't seem to be unless you'll never
admit Raymond I've never been invited to
like someone's compound
I've never do you know what I mean I
have never been I have no friends it
went to Ivy League's you never show up
to a party in high school you weren't
invited to yep ray Long Island party
it's a different story we make a [ __ ]
nice mac and cheese we make a [ __ ]
quiche I know but I'm saying that I
oh so you're saying that's the way we
should get in some night show with the
key we bring a bottle of champagne now I
like by your talk but don't you ever say
I just want to be listen I'm in the
inner sanctum of comedy and I realized
how much it sucks right then I
it's not that it sucks he's just
different from the rest of you guys so
all of you out there that think that
it's gonna be a certain way once you get
in these groups
it ain't that it's not what you think
right it's just what it is you know
sometimes you'll you'll be around people
and you'll be like this is somewhat
different than I'd imagined I just want
to know I wonder if you burrow into the
elite sanctum you know the inner side I
don't think they like it
I don't except for the guys like like
like who actually with the hands like a
lot to offer Raymond I'm saying we would
but we would that's the point
they were trying to preserve anything
right these guys like Jeff Bezos we're
gonna go Gators laughs they're
disrupting and becoming rich and and
pushing out the old beat yes and like
and the more power or like when
rockefeller and carnal is that why they
won't let us in they're afraid of us I'm
trying to follow your point yes they're
afraid we're better than that Raven we
could do a better job but they can do it
all but the point is their job is to be
pleased to preserve the the wealth that
came before you let us in because we're
charismatic and they fear us yeah and
they use us because no one likes us and
we're not attractive exactly that's
interesting but it can't really
blackmail us or use us in any sexual way
they can [ __ ] us but we'll let them [ __ ]
us it's interesting but they can't
really use that because we'll just let
people [ __ ] does it really matter
Iran is all you four years ago and I win
friends I just love it that's that's
what your character Good Will Hunting
writes on the on the on the chalkboard
they all gone he [ __ ] me let's take a
look at this theorem that he came out
there what he wrote down he [ __ ] it
that's what he came up with but here's
my old thing
I've always had a fascination with you
later Dave never they've never had that
fascination back with me I mean you you
you're you're very good crowd work I
don't know if they have material
say that you say no I mean that looks
great jokes I love you you Navy SEAL biz
great it's a fun one longer pizza you
Epstein bits great you're fun point is I
don't know if they value that as much as
we do
interesting I don't I think they tend to
now here's the thing they all can't be
[ __ ] and eating children no but
they're [ __ ] like grown women or men
rights they're doing something they're
doing cog look when you you you know
more like you haven't dealt with the
elite but you've dealt with rich drug
addicts a little bit right yeah so it
doesn't seem like compared to the way
you enjoy drugs they enjoy it less grant
yeah enjoy everything less is less
thrilled to it give enjoy everything
less yes at this point is a numbing
effect
these are saying it's better than be
poor right well you know bub saying has
not say that but my point is like I
don't think that they appreciate it they
would they would they would kill
themselves as they became poor right but
they don't have the context to really
get thrill out of it or you enjoy the
way that you will you great you know
like look if Prescott Bush's grandson
whoever he is Archie Bush whoever within
the cast within the Pierce butch was in
the car with us when you're yelling at a
Taco Bell worker for leaving at your
nacho cheese I think it's hilarious yeah
we thought you'd like to attack but you
know jump through the window I want I
want the best for people yeah and when I
see them not performing their tasks but
and listen I only yelled right because
she laughed at me she just and you
she laughed you knew she laughed in my
face right would you said you want I
think she'd laugh because you said I
want nacho cheese now I want to dip my
like apple slices in it no one else this
is why the bagel guy was not that wrong
yeah there are people that let that she
just laughed at me she thought I was
funny I was not trying to be funny
no you're nothing to worry about and
right but and I just went at her and I
and you know you make a whole big deal
out of this you keep bringing it up no
it's a fun I liked it predictable she
that was really starting just terrible
she was a terrible person yeah she's
proud
ms-13 so she has nothing to fear from me
right but now that I'm recounting this I
understand why many of the elites would
not be a party like there's gonna be
like can you shut me off like they're
not gonna show your company right they
they don't like unpredictability
yeah a little bit of a wild card
yeah I guess you're right I guess that's
what it is I'm a little bit of a wild
card and so are you yeah but we should
be proud of that
I am proud that's what America is I'm
trusted to these guys we're American and
you're doing a great job baby we're
America I'm just it's interesting to me
when you walk around a yale and you go
you know what these people aren't better
than us I don't believe they are better
than now some of them are but I think
we're as smart as they are we're smart
we're smart you are smart you are smart
but I feel like we just lack discipline
we lack what would have had to happen in
our lives think about this
yeah for us to have gotten into skaaland
bones um we've never had a shot no I'm
all right even if I got into Yale like
right I think look they look at you if
you look at our parents take for them
poor yeah why cuz I mean they look at us
probably worse than like scholarship
like blow income people who get
scholarships like pure like our parents
earn we're worse than that we're worse
yeah to them I mean like uh well yeah I
think our level like when they would
they think of as poor as people whose
parents are like you know successful
surgeons right or like you know the only
small company and Oren's are the
president of an international bank right
like so I don't know that even if we got
in I mean we'd have to do something like
the cap day a statue like you're like
yeah we'd have to really make we have to
burn down the food court or whatever
they call it you know we have to like
imagine we bring down the food court
because we thought of get us in a skull
balls ended up in jail like what are you
idiots we wanted to make a statement we
burned down the food court thinking
we're gonna get cat in the suckers
collar bone and now we're in jail can
somebody please if you if somebody
please my dumb
fans are all gonna by the way do this
and I could somebody please DM me
anonymously and tell me about how they
got into skullenbones or scrolling key
or wolf's head or any of the
opportunities make it Instagram account
just DM me anonymously now I know what
I've just invited and I know that it's
just gonna be a million people calling
me fat but please seriously if you are
serious about it do a dummy account will
never know who you are just DM me and
tell me how it happened and grease the
wheels to grease the wheels you can [ __ ]
us you can [ __ ] listen you want to come
in here and [ __ ] us you can [ __ ] us even
if you need a real human sacrifice so
many of our friends will gladly be
sacrificed by you I look whether they go
to the bar every night riding my podcast
please listen to my podcast more maybe I
won't feel this way but it's like it's
starting to feel like it here's the deal
if you let us in for just a week
sacrifice yeah sacrifice both of us it's
a great ending it's a great ending let
us in show us how it really is and then
light us on fire
now what if they did that and they they
go this sacrifice won't even appease the
gods like won't even like we can't even
do this hey we sacrifice young virgins
whoa
you swaps you fat the occult [ __ ] is
weird though right I mean it is
interesting but it is book I mean
Washington DC the amount of symbolism
yeah it's super weird you wouldn't have
to go that far to go like oh it's a
design like a pentagram so I can channel
energy from saying we do enough evil
[ __ ] whether we're challenged that's the
thing that's the say the same thing
we're like why does it matter if the
kids [ __ ] are wearing gold does it
matter why is it matter if like the
George Washington statue is is designed
to have to bother me what it is is it
and what it does is it just it it it
here's what it really does it
illustrates how wrong you could have
gotten everything sure that's what I
think I think it's also you think
the idea of like they wander but the
Pope Noah like don't you [ __ ] around
there's something to that back when the
vet when they were the vac in that form
still also Church of England yeah you
think it was certain level of lighters
absolutely that type of paganism was was
was a way to because he liked that did
kind of play with secularism and all
that like yeah and this symbolism of
Freemasonry was like about enlightenment
but there's also like hey like Church of
England or [ __ ] Pope but like we got
our own thing going on I think yeah I
think part of it was a hundred temper
sad Nick bride said it perfectly he's
like some of it is is is optics and the
appearance of things and egos some of it
is not there are some people that are
you know really a cultist that are
deadly serious about it you know who's
who very hard to know no rank they are
who's very hard because me and you have
been kept completely out of every circle
of you know other than the comedy the
elite and and here's what I because the
elite in comedy I've been allowed into
that circle just seeing some of the
funniest people in the world and it's
not necessarily what you would think
right it's just not what you would think
it doesn't mean it's better or worse
which is kind of different right so I I
wonder if you got it I'm sure this call
them both kind of sucks I'm sure it cuz
you nobody else really that good-looking
I was walking around looking at Yale I'm
like these kids aren't that hot cuz
they're smart they're not that hot I
mean much hotter this is like you kind
of saying I know you've dealt with
executives people but like it's calling
these people the elite of comedy
it's like calling Coltrane e elite of
jazz yeah he was but like that means
like he's the most talented ever or one
of them but like doesn't mean like the
talent is never the Kuang Quan Li
doesn't really go ahead interesting like
they Li are people like David Geffen who
runs the record in well you you
understand what I mean what I'm saying
is that I've had a vantage point to see
comedy at its highest levels but really
nothing else
I've never girls I've read about a lot
of other things but the only rooms that
I've ever been in where you've seen some
of the top people in an industry right
have been in common
sure but you're still not like in a
closed room with Lorne like but I'm
pretty close my point is I know what
those rooms are
like I've heard the stories from those
rooms firsthand right my point is that
gang is the tentacles into comedy from
power aren't really that many and they
don't really get used for that much and
we've got like it's crazy war you've
kind of done you know a lot waste on
your nose is rightfully cuz you know
they well they're just right I mean are
you correct I'm not I'm not a I'm not a
guy the industry of comedy respects and
I'm very funny but I'm also not a guy
that they consider to be malleable right
and there ya know 100 percent I'm just
wondering when I walk around an
institution with Yale I'm like I wonder
how wrong we have it or how right we are
question I think the yeah the I think
it's just what what's interesting to me
is they probably seen some horrific [ __ ]
or there or in front of it if they're
one degree separate from some horrific
[ __ ] but the levels of boredom that they
have we know so like less wax nerds kid
yeah supposedly is like a Bonesmen right
so like is that weird does anyone turn
around and go hey like what's going on
with dad why did not I don't think he
talks is good about it but I think when
you're news when you're his kid yeah
that's the kind of successional well
you're his kid you know the stories you
guess what's up you start piecing things
it's kinds of pram those with the kids
starting to realize that that hey like
oh is that why would anything I was
doing there oh that who that guy in oh
that guy's oh hey okay and so as you
come of age you it's not so much he ever
tells you per se but you kind of go oh I
probably got to start doing some dirt
you know I probably got a sort of
[ __ ] well just interesting you wonder
like what gets talked about in a place
like that will summer break it out will
somebody bring something like that up
um what's a great park is very like very
rarely prop but that's what I mean you
would but it also oh they're all doing
drugs aren't they
I don't you think you would think so
right well I would think you're having
stared college yeah their guard down
yeah no I think they talk about it I
think since Monday they probably bond
over like you know kill people to look
like what I don't think those parents
ever tell the kids that much maybe
they're not older I mean the 50 of
course you're not telling the kids that
much I'm just wondering what like you
wonder in
group yeah are they Boy Scouts are they
like a man I don't know [ __ ] happens
like no no no no smart enough I don't
they're not that stupid
they look they're they don't have the
ambition of a true sociopath
like there are certain kind of sociopath
but the kind who get into that Club on
his own but they they're not bored like
that it's the kind of thing where they
think they're like decent guys but like
they've all witnessed a trace does
nothing they've all gotten chick strong
like they've all paid many of them yeah
I'm saying is kind of a be not maybe I'm
wondering if these kids are kind of like
Cox and I by the way I'm not saying that
I'm not saying that nond a rapist got
but I mean like maybe they're not doing
drugs and partying bit mix maybe some of
them are maybe they're you know how many
of them are Malfoy and how many of them
are Ron from Harry Potter how do you
read Harry Potter well I did when I was
a kid don't give me a face like you
better than me when I was a kid I
watched an animal form it's a kid yeah
you're reading a before you want to see
what your future is no III think most
like look if you'll get drug used for in
general with rich kids it's like pretty
common stereotype don't love them and a
bike drug problems look like that Robert
Cohen stuff my dad got me that Robert
Kawasaki River book and like yeah it's
really hard for rich kids for instance
to like build wealth on their own and
not to be Parag priors on their family's
wealth like it's hard so if you're if
you're part of that system I think it's
hard for a lot of them to like not [ __ ]
around with drugs and alcohol and then
like push boundaries those parents are
always like high power people who aren't
paying attention anyway so like why
wouldn't it begin the trouble so the
odds of them being Boy Scouts it's like
that stitch I'm wrong on that yeah I
think so they're smarter they're shrewd
yeah they see how but they have a sense
of like their dad has like he drops a
little pearls of wisdom like you know
Qaddafi thought you were smart too so
it's like they I think they get the
whiff of it and by the time they're in
college I think they're pissed ants in a
lot of ways I think they're and they
don't really know I'm not saying they're
qualified to do any of the dirt
real dirt but I think that I don't I I
think that they're totally willing and
think and think more of themselves and
they are and they they think they're
bred for this when it's a horse [ __ ] but
they think they're bred for it and I
think the arrogance of thinking you're
bright for it is a lot of it the
arrogance that builds into you makes you
into the kind of sociopath that
eventually can because all you're really
doing is manipulating the wheels of
power Kurt Vonnegut we must be careful
what we pretend to be yeah yeah yeah
really that's really what it is very
interesting very interesting discussion
and and what it would really hits home
to me is that we will we will never ever
ever ever even accidentally be welcomed
into well if we get a job at the local
pizzeria and we do we deliver a pizza
one day we bide our time you know what
if we're delivered yes like in in in
March of the wooden soldiers we get
delivered we pose as hookers and we we
could we pop out of a box
yeah or a bomb I have a bomb I think
that and you know what owns like your
island would own skull bones Russell
trust Association I also think they
owned Yale I mean it's like it's big
money and big power players and you know
what I mean I gotta be honest with you
he's anything they're more elite than
what goes on at Nassau Community College
which is where success starts and
continues you kid but I mean I've it is
the top Community College in the country
I've heard that like they've they've had
like past ten years like 30 people
become like partners at Goldman have you
ever been in the top flight food court
no well it's phenomenal it used to have
a Taco Bell I would get a grilled
stuffed burrito it's it's nice does go
up and recruit on that so actually I was
kidding with them really um I would say
no okay but I'll tell you who does the
Suffolk PD I'll tell you who does
recruit out of Nassau Community College
let's take fact that campus put the
Brentwood campus of Suffolk right and
it's a shame oh yeah Merman sucks angle
that
the Brentwood oh that's still wet
Brentwood is like they don't even have
grass it's just like crabgrass and like
and the buildings are all just like they
look like that uh like a Branch Davidian
complex or something well it's what the
people deserve with your wait I would
like to go back to Yale with you
yeah um let's go now uber well no I want
to go get the Christmas log cake right
now I love a Swiss roll Christmas cake
it's scheitz
it's very and uh and at the restaurant
that's doing a taquito um are you still
Quito yep you monkey been wearing
smaller pants he's a Quito man with a
Quito plant a bug and I'm just getting
the hard digging and strong abs well I
don't know about that I haven't seen is
good for your blood flow it might be no
but I also think that you know there's
all kinds of debates about what is good
and what isn't good look at the end the
day who know that healthy I'm like being
massively overweight isn't healthy
either the only bite the bullet the
reality is being alive isn't healthy
yeah let's be honest being alive is not
healthy right that's the reality how
many times have I told you to clean up
your dick or your does the manscape work
on a female area no this is for men this
is for men just like government and
business this is for men it's a joke
that's a joke you don't want to have a
furry overly furry dick because people
get upset when you pull it out they
don't like it you pull it out different
places fast-food restaurants or a train
station people get angry but if it's if
it's if it's well cropped even if
they're upset that you're exposing
yourself in public if you have a
well-trimmed bush people will notice
that even when they report you even when
they say there's somebody streaking here
and they've taken their dick out in
front of a large group of people they'll
say but I will be honest
with you it was trim it was you know it
was you know wasn't a mess down there
you know it's interesting that this type
of gentleman who takes that care would
choose to expose himself in the way that
he did but I guess he's just proud of
what he's done so that's what manscaped
is about it's about giving you the
confidence to expose yourself in places
it's about basically making sure that
your pubic region is in the best shape
possible so that you can take your dick
out wherever you want whenever you want
and people are gonna be ok with it you
know not in a sexual way where you're
pressuring someone but just in a group
setting when you could just take your
penis out and ask people sometimes you
don't even have to reference it you just
tip my friend used to take his balls out
and just hang them out of his shorts
like through the through the zipper and
he just wouldn't say anything in his
balls about her to be it's funny you
should do that in your office it's fun
to take your dick out if you like your
dick or if you can make peace with the
kind of dick you have so that's what
manscaped has asked me to communicate to
you is that this is certainly about
cleaning yourself up using the ball
deodorizer a lot deodorizer using the
what do they call them band the trimmer
that the manscape that chopped the
lawnmower correct the lawnmower used the
lawn mower whether you're a grower or a
show or you use the lawn mower and then
you take a dig out wherever you want
take you if Luisi Cade use this he
wouldn't even be in trouble you know
what I mean just take it out [ __ ] take
it out but make sure that even the
lawnmower is a good product I'm telling
you you take extra care you're not gonna
Nick yourself you're not gonna you know
have any adverse effects it's very hard
to really
take the care and attention and you
don't have to do that you don't have to
worry about hurting yourself you just
have to worry about how great your dick
is gonna look because that's gonna be
weird too when you're that happy you
know you just shave yourself and take
your dick out take your dick out
don't start beating it just leave it be
take it out and just let it let people
appreciate it
that's what manscaping wants me to tell
you they don't want their the good work
of their product to go unnoticed they
want you to take your penis out at your
job that's why they make the product so
that you can clean yourself up so that
you can expose yourself at work this is
this is why they have a company it's so
that you can take your penis out at your
job and not be afraid that people are
gonna get weird about it because you are
really taking care of down there your
well trimmed your well groomed that is
the goal of this company and that's the
goal of this it is a great product I
like it I use it I know people that use
it you need it if your dude you need
this product why not buy this one
support the show but also it's it's it's
more it's about more than just that it's
about giving you the confidence to take
your penis out at your job that's what
it's about
and and and showing it to everybody and
saying hey this is my penis you know
obviously if you work with children it's
inappropriate don't do it you know if
you work with the elderly it's also
inappropriate could give them you know I
don't know stroke or something but if
you're with legal age people take your
dick out at your job that's what I want
to communicate to you
we present off free shipping of the code
Tim at manscape comm manscape comm 20%
off free shipping the code Tim these
things really work folks they really
work get'em khmer alright everybody what
a dinner that wasn't I mean it was me it
was me a little disappointing there was
a lot of fat I mean the thing here's the
thing you asked
I don't disparage the woman she meant
well she was being able to flirty for my
taste
she was she grabbed your arm the
waitress grabbed your arm yeah now when
you grab a man like your arm right she's
taking her life in her hand I'm gonna I
mean I ain't get hard but like yo but
here's the thing if you'll you might
just bite well I'm not gonna bite it
well certainly just as your reaction
look I'm just saying I'm in a healthy
relationship I'm getting laid I'm being
doesn't matter that's that's nothing or
there I'm being milked but my point is
that you know certain point I come
certain times in my life I'm more lonely
that human contact I get a taste for it
maybe I start seeking it out you know it
also is very expensive was you had what
three Bourbons - oh just - yeah I think
you had three I - are you sure one of
the third I said no okay
two Bourbons that's fine yeah I'm sorry
no you can have as much bourbon as you
want you know I think by you know her
touch you caressing your arm like that
yeah she's taking her life in her hands
I might have better I probably will have
better you just worst case I'm saying I
would have like grabbed her heads what I
almost started petting her head here's
what I could see happening yeah she
caressed she caresses you yeah you turn
around and grab her hand and now she
automatically knows she made a mistake
I looked deeply into rising oh I feel
something - I feel something - and she
immediately knows now what does she do
is it like an anaconda because when
you're an out of cod to bite you because
it's teeth curved backward you have to
actually force your hand deeper into its
mouth before you can get it out
what does she do did she just pull away
or did she caress you a little bit even
though she's very fearful terrified for
her life
why would I was caressing you see you
loosen up the thing in nano say you know
to stick it in deeper but no but like
yes she but she was a little too
familiar we were talking at dinner about
the lack of real activism when it comes
to Hollywood people like yes because
some of it would be a little funny right
like you know why isn't like Liz or
truther it would be funny if Liz Oh with
but not a 9/11 truth ending up true for
Sandy Hook truth cuz Liz Oh does these
things on stage before she performs
where she goes I want you to put your
lights up that light represents the
light inside you and I want you to look
at yourself and you say I love you
because you're beautiful
and I want you to look around and
realize that you were the only one you
need I want you to also ask yourself
this question why would they build
another school where the Sandy Hook high
school was does that make any sense to
you it's good well whatever it was
middle school why would they level a
building and build a completely new one
that doesn't make any sense
that's all right and then she would just
go into her stuff you know yeah I just I
just picture like her having that giant
ass and there's also like a facility a
fast meal well you call it for simile
facsimile of building savage collapsing
of yourself ladies love yourself and
also realize let's be honest that the
Mossad planted the bombs in the towers
your children are crisis active your
children have you ever met anybody that
died in Sandy Hook I don't think so
there are no death certificates for any
where are the death certificates for the
kids okay drum roll home what's his name
little Zeke or little I don't know lose
an Little John Rose and he doesn't even
know where he is Elohim City yeah Elohim
you know
I did this you know remember Tarun Zeki
he [ __ ] yo son just he damn [ __ ] cuz
he knew the big fade did not act alone
alright now here's my new song is called
I love you [ __ ] who do you think would
do worse in a crowd there was there is
he'll is Owen little balloons and the
Beastie Boys are Dick Cheney look the
Cheney would do better
no the BC boys would do a lot better it
might as well be you're not as relevant
they're so relevant my friend Michelle
want to go see them when they were in
Brooklyn um I just love an interview
with Dozier cat where she really starts
talking about you know like you know
some like where she just goes off about
the Annunaki yeah and they're like
listen you know Juicy's about but she's
like years about buts
but it's like also about that we were
created as slaves to mind for an atomic
gold which is the only way that the
Annunaki on their planet it's the only
way they could breathe I believe that
[ __ ] your third eye your [ __ ] you
can see through your [ __ ] and it's
like your pineal gland you have to open
your [ __ ] up because that is where
you're going to see the truth through
your [ __ ] that's why it's protected
by all that fat that good beautiful fat
gelatinous fat but yet none of these
[ __ ] people none of them take it
where it should go
I mean look they all want to talk [ __ ]
about like it's got everybody's woke but
nobody's really woke yeah no one no like
it's like oh you know [ __ ] in the
COINTELPRO right but no wants to admit
like yeah thank my manager of my agent I
want to thank all the fans and I want to
thank Larry Silverstein for Sam bullet
audibly on tape before buildings never
came down he said pullin [ __ ]
listeners was dumb wife he's a [ __ ]
my wife so a skin tag I get a skin I
just want to say this the dream come
true to stand up here in the American
musical wars with so many talented
people I also want to say let's be out
if they had a million death camps
working 24 hours a day they never could
have got to 6 billion that's the way it
is that's just the way it is we just see
people like what stop mid clap just
really confused why doesn't that happen
more often why do people why don't
people just have likes like almost have
a mini-stroke and say something crazy
more often why don't the people who've
been given houses in Laguna Beach yeah
question the Wow you know what I didn't
know like these people are on so many
drugs a lot of them yes somehow they
stand out this is where people can also
to be they're gonna be like mind control
but it's like every now and then like
Sean Penn would have a slip or Kanye
Kanye put it like interesting that
ballsiest cutting as much as you don't
really give a [ __ ] or supposedly doesn't
give a [ __ ] you remember that like black
George Bush doesn't care about black but
even that he looked nervous well sure
because that was you know I mean let's
say in like what sort of someone just
really like when they do have those
little spurts it always comes up no
one's just going like drop in knowledge
it's gonna balls yeah well it's just
that listen the system works and they're
not going to jeopardize what they have
but I just find it funny that like you
know Roseanne goes off right sure
Roseanne's wild but she's also mentally
ill I think you gotta have a little
mental illness to risk so much you gotta
realize your little yeah well first of
all like I think she's a little more
freewheeling after she lost the show
yeah that she wasn't pretty pretty out
there she was pretty she's pretty but
she's also such a maniac
yeah like even though like I think a lot
Hill thought well she's so crazy there
was gonna take it seriously anyway and
then she kind of went further than they
thought she would look you argued a home
tweet thing it did come to me it came up
was she wearing the clothes of dr. Zaius
I get but you know it came off like woo
why should be in that racist yeah did it
look good but in general what she's like
no the crystals in the I think she's no
gable [ __ ] I just think she's one of the
only people that even looks into that I
think a lot of people out there it's a
wide like numbers know the counting of
the numbers
and he's nonsense anything she's just
one of the only people that looks into
how the government is run I don't think
a lot of people don't really know if she
is though what do you mean well I mean
it's given on [ __ ] some of it is some of
its not some of its I listen to her you
know the whole thing here's my thing I
love you an odd [ __ ] to get popular I
mean you know don't kill Epstein don't
sure I love a crazy woman as much as the
next guy
yeah I was I'm just saying I don't think
that these people even have a clue like
a lot of the people that are in
Hollywood that are actors or actresses
or big musicians I don't think they I
don't think they've looked into anything
what do you do Kylie Jenner's good I
mean look Kim with one thing but but
Kylie Jenner does she just thinks she's
like either Egyptian god or some [ __ ]
like she's just I'm like like if she
even realized how [ __ ] cuz I feel like
Kim you know she had to have a porn tape
first and there was a little it was a
little more messy and then she had the
reality show but Kylie is like a
billionaire she's like well like 9 16
years old yeah I'm just saying like she
just thinks she's like a [ __ ]
reincarnated like God like the she even
realized how because she should be
Ground Zero of knowing how [ __ ] it is
because she's part of this weird
apparatus but I feel like she does you
guys gave Kylie Jenner is questioning
things if she's questioning I'm asking
if she's reading the nest then that's
report on building seven I don't think
so no but seriously she is she is she
questioning like is she aware wow I'm
just getting over or she just dilute
like self delusion I think she's getting
over I think they're a smart family
right their food they know how to
[ __ ] operate and they're they're just
[ __ ] dude I know some people that
know them just I don't you know I never
met them I don't know anything about
them that's that's I know a few people
that dole them but just they're all
about business you know Kris Jenner is
about business they're [ __ ] just you
know so I mean she started what if she's
a billionaire cuz of a makeup line yeah
I don't putting it down I'm not sure but
I'm just saying yeah I mean you know you
realize like you're like
you're part of this weird nexus of
reality TV and sort of a porn thing is
weird like a sexualized they feel guilty
about Trump that's an interesting
question like to any of those people
realize that the world that they helped
build sure people Donald Trump I don't
really well I mean I feel like he was
doing his show before they didn't they
I'm talking about the the world I'm
talking about and I'm not saying that
they're responsible yeah I'm just
wondering if they ever look at what you
know they you know contributed to and
the type of celebrity obsessed culture I
mean Trump comes from an obsession with
celebrity and celebrity culture that's
all that's left in America you know that
everything's rotted the only thing we
have left is an obsession with celebrity
I got a little vote for them it'll be
easy for me to agree with that but I
kind of feel like Trump is this kind of
primal celebrity that's almost like a
Barnum and a PT Barnum type exactly what
they are and he but exactly what I'm
saying he would have he would have
resonated in Hades we didn't he wasn't
president he absolutely wouldn't have
trouble either point is impossible
without the card - yeah people like that
but Trump doesn't exist without the Real
Housewives without the the the onslaught
of reality television where you're
watching a show that it's fake and you
don't care let's go with me for a second
you're watching something that isn't
real and you don't care and you still
enjoy it and you know that the you know
that it's heavily manufactured and that
you know best-case heavily manufactured
worst case completely manufactured and
you don't care and you still enjoy it
because it's real enough it's just real
enough
the houses are real the outfits are
things they might wear they live in the
places that they live but the actual
interactions and things are all heavily
you know manufactured arranged I think
without that and I think that and
everyone focuses on social media which
is absolutely true you know social media
has made us more coarse and callous and
the way we deal with each other and
process information but if you look at
reality television the way that that's
helped shape culture I mean the way that
people act on a reality show the way
that they act well
how aggressive they are that they just
fight each other that they throw wine at
each other and that you enjoy the
spectacle of that okay and I mean it's
it's aromachology a very point around
forever I mean the way is the latest
manifestation away he bought a bunch of
sexual assault victims to a debate a
hundred percent yeah no your this is a
move that is it's it's a move from the
series finesse season finale of your
favorite show and reality TV is the
world that you know America you know is
a reality show right and you know people
said that and it's kind of like I don't
wanna say hack at this point but it's a
cliche thing to say but it is a reality
show people yeah you turn on the news
now not to get news right you turn it on
for drama what is the big selling point
for reality TVs drop well there's a
weird thing world enough and we and you
I think you use a kid watch some news as
a kid like Jan remember what the news
was like I remember the news kids who
were like 20 now didn't grow up with
that at all have no idea a really the
news was boring not saying they think
the news is born cuz they hate they
don't care about anything right but the
news used to be I mean if you watch the
NBC Nightly News it's still a little dry
right but I mean like but no one's
watching that I'll tell you this kids
that are growing up now nothing is
boring right the idea that anything is
boring everything is entertaining unless
they turn it off we used to have like
people saw this PBS destroyed that but
like brother used to have sure but the
PBS look when you watch PBS now if
you're a young person listening
go watch the Jim Lehrer news hour on PBS
is right that's what like was a warps
yeah and that's been his dead now but
Herrick compared writing Charlie Gibson
sand Donelson Cokie Roberts the most you
got was what's-his-name the McLaughlin
Gray he was still a [ __ ] like
geriatric Shawn McLaughlin is a
Wallflower compared to any of the people
that compared to [ __ ] Tommy Lehren
right compared to Alex Jones
compared to you know anybody I mean even
a maniac like Pat Buchanan
he's still sitting there most of the
time not saying crazy [ __ ] I mean could
be responding the quest compare that to
Bill O'Reilly can hear that T Hannity
and Colmes a Buchanan would just be like
well no I think you just know you should
be explaining answer and then sometimes
he would say [ __ ] but you know whatever
you know before but mean like that's a
he was a clown but I mean like it is the
level of theatrics that the news has
become well part of that I think is that
you know 24-hour news CNN came in in the
1990s Iraq war and then like the OJ
Simpson trial changed a lot of it people
that was the first news story that I
think ran round the clock and then we've
we started the process of becoming a
tabloid I know that Nancy Grace really
was the final level of it it wasn't good
issues maybe that I think the final
evidence I'm Donald Trump and I think
the other night as far as like could be
even with even Grenaa Susteren Van
Susteren she was much better than before
the plastic surgery thing but like that
like her she going made her name up for
Court TV in the OJ trial but she was
still like oh she used to be a
journalist and she's kind of a
respectable person well he did this
whole idea that you had point
counterpoint right like the political it
ization
of the news to where it was like this
guy says this I say that point
counterpoint there are no facts there's
just interpretations of a story and then
the idea that you had two people on
either side of it and that then you had
two networks on either side of it then
you go to Fox at MSNBC right and then
you know things just splintered into a
million different versions of reality
and yeah now so it's interesting like
where what is the next iteration because
we're a tabloid country where a
celebrity obsessed culture where does
that go like where do people get totally
turned off by that eventually and what
is then because here's what I'm watching
now I'm starting to kind of watch like
Jeffrey star who's this trans very
wealthy guy on YouTube was huge and like
III don't watch it but I like I like try
to keep tabs on what what's going on on
like
because in LA it's hard to ignore like
the height beasts these kids that buy
sneakers just oh my phone yeah they
stole your phone I try to do that on
stage when I do your acts and everything
but the reality is there's there's
there's an interesting level of
materialism like Geoffrey start Shane
Dawson just released his conspiracy
theory I believe like line of makeup yes
yeah I'm not kidding they did this thing
on YouTube called conspiracy theories
where they investigate conspiracy
theories I don't know if you're familiar
with this this is a no this this guy
Jeffrey each star is I mean look him up
look up Geoffrey star I'm talking about
massive we're talking about in terms of
YouTube numbers you know maybe one of
the biggest youtubers so Geoffrey star
just to give you an idea his channel he
got sixteen point seven million
subscribers okay I'm only sixteen point
seven million and now Shane Dawson who's
like oh this is a trans person yeah and
then Shane Dawson you know you're
looking at his channel he's got 23
million subscribers so then he did this
they do this thing you know conspiracy
theories and there was a make up is it
Jeffrey Stehr approved so here's here's
news what's interesting about all this
stuff this kind of rampant materialism
right which I've noticed like well
there's an office that makeup kid was
like is that guy's name that young kid
yeah I don't know but he is like seven
million viewers there seems to be a real
obsession yeah with makeup with
accessories yes clothing that by the way
there was always fashion when I grew up
there was always like the idea Gucci and
Prada and whatever figure you know and
and and and then there was always Styles
there was you know I grew up with like
baggy jeans and their veggies Jenkins
I starter jacket yes materialism isn't
new but there's this new iteration of it
right and it's very interesting and I
wonder where that go here's I mean look
it's crazy
I wonder if because like you watch these
guys and again he's make them kids and
like the plastic level of it and I and
like I don't think most of the people
watching it or well you when I watched
that video
I feel sick not because the guys like
him has style or as glamorous but just
like it's also faking and weird I get
depressed right is what kids are like I
don't think kids I think it's just more
like I don't like I think a lot of the
kids are just watching and going like
yeah not really
but that being said like it's so fake
it's you know overdone
it's so over the top what you know what
is the attraction to that is it because
there's such an emptiness all around us
that the idea that something is so
almost like it's like a fairy tale or
it's like the way people are made up
it's like it's there so we look at pop
music right
they look mystical I don't know they're
there there are they is is this a thing
of this an offshoot of comic book movies
maybe I don't know they look at pop
music right yeah and the way we like it
well our generation has become an outlet
you are opening for douji cat of course
a lot of people think that I'm lying
about that you are opening for notion a
so how did you meet her I was at Arby's
yeah and I was throwing up on in the
bathroom and now what was it was it bad
meat or was it too much I hate to say
too much okay and she's banging on the
door guy I think it's [ __ ] right come
out and go you look framers or some and
she's like [ __ ] I'm dozer cat him Dylan
talks about you did you go with that fat
greasy maggot but uh well we got some
kind of drinks in the and Patrick in
handy and paper cops and Arby's yeah
she said why don't you know are you
gonna do music what are you gonna do I'm
gonna do my synth music but also like
III think about rock music everybody
have that and I'm gonna do like spoken
word over we got to do a show in LA
where you just use amazing shiny all
right so we grew up rumors too
yeah so look the Rolling Stones and the
Beatles and like they were good
musicians right but then you have like
the generation after all he's a van
halen's and I'm saying like there was
like we grew up in the 90s grunge
Nirvana right and Mike and everybody was
kind of gently they believe troubled
guys that but all the other bands around
them there was a definite currency in
authentic miss what we don't want yeah
yeah the right and we and like whether
it was horseshit but there was a value
to that and we and you need to have it
and even pop music at the time wasn't as
much that like Milli Vanilli but they
found it a but lip-sync they were
shunned right and that's gone now
well yeah anyone caring if anyone like
like I might even say that no one's
authentic but that no one cares if you
were that's not part of the living
country music part of yeah no I think
you're absolutely right part of the
attraction to a lot of these people is
that they do style themselves as I don't
want to use the word freaks in a
negative way but like people that are so
over the top right and so out of this
world that you wouldn't necessarily
muris to luxurious as your buddy contra
points opulence like but the idea of it
just being over it's just overkill you
know what bugs me about it
you look at Z star dust or like Aladdin
Sane Bowie's most different books yeah
and personalities and he was doing it at
a time when like no one there's only
wanted it was weird like so much this
stuff now it's like no one even does no
one said I mean I'm sure like there's
the [ __ ] pastors out there going this
is the devil you think part of it is
that people have actually gotten pretty
boring and they're they're they're
actually trying to figure out a way to
seem unique and different whatever so
but that that social
median technologies kind of flattened
people whereas people and and they're
corralled very easily into all liking
one thing so that individuality 'he's
got have been destroyed the only way to
do it is you just paint yourself I mean
I I see it myself but I it's always just
you know me being a blowhard idiot but
you know but I'm a relatively new on sir
person and I'm at the money I have good
tweet sometimes like then people you
know some frozen aids why you instruct
your client to answer the question the
question was when was the last time he
saw the victim of this crime he said
he's a nuance person and that he has
good tweets the question was when is the
last time you saw the victim of this
crime
Arbus keep going now my point is like ya
know like it's what's rewarded generally
speaking is more mild syllabic or more
like things that are just kind of more
digestible so that's one element of it
but it's also we were talking before but
yeah wisdom is great and likewise people
don't hook has yes good but like it's
not Whitney Houston right I mean recent
Franklin like right there isn't like I
don't know where cuz so much of it now
goes into the marketing a lot of it is
the marketing and it's not so much I
mean I mean I think it's interesting and
I think so what you what you see now is
you seen on the left of the riot you see
like these discredited ideas whether
it's communism or whether it's fascism
or whether it's you know white supremacy
or whether it's jus conspiracy theories
like Julia sorry but they all come back
we all you know and there's something
interesting about the idea that maybe we
are reaching the end of a stage mmm and
that because technology has gotten that
we are going to you can technologies
become so you know powerful that the
next stage of our life is going to be
unlike any that we could imagine like
it's not going to be because we seem to
be in a loop where we're just trot we
have the same problems we had 100 years
ago
other than the you know that have been
made better by
technology or medicine or whatever yeah
we have the same issues with each other
you know the same problems we have a lot
of the same conspiracy theories we have
the same fear as we have the same it may
be at a certain point it's just we're on
the verge of taking that next leap into
whatever the future is gonna be in it it
might be where the human era is over I
mean it's interesting because I'm never
gonna be ones guys like who oh is it too
much ah not opulence but like
permissiveness and society it'll [ __ ]
but there is something weird that
happens when the permissive doesn't
really wanna call it or just the the
lack of taboo in society means that art
has no more power there right there is
no potency to art ever any more right
it's really almost nothing you do
shocked and now that you want like shock
effect in the art per se but that out
like you like even South Park it was
just great and still it's so brilliant
isn't really shocking people which and
like that like you there's well those
things I would say that it's I think
it's a great point about the
permissiveness in society but it's also
what happens when the satire becomes the
news like Trump is the president
Kardashian Kim Kardashian is at the
White House campaigning for it well
that's what I mean the over the
overstimulation and your yeah there
isn't I mean all of the possibilities or
many of them have been realized we are
at a point now where to satirize or you
can't heighten anything anymore we've
talked about that right and you just
wonder at a certain point where it's
like how you know the human race in
general it's like you know at you know
are we at the furthest we can go I mean
is look
there's different types of
totalitarianism right like the Nazis
clearly evil style and evil the Roman
Empire killed a lot of people yeah but I
feel like it was a little less like you
know race driven maybe I don't know
regardless I'm not promoting it but is
this kind of almost natural like the
matrix through the hole and he meets
that [ __ ] the colonel
the Colonel Sanders guy my point is a
cyclical is this thing of like yeah
like you know society you'll get to a
point where every because this is kind
of month your Rome and Caligula and away
in Nero and that's well wait here's the
problem will we as biological beings are
just not efficient which is not right
and the phone that we hold in our hand
all the technology around us is so much
more efficient than we are but we're
kind of gumming up the system yeah with
our stupid ideas right right without
racism our whatever we're just coming it
out we're fighting with each other you
just see is what it is at a certain
point we're gonna have to be made more
efficient and I don't know how that's
gonna happen I don't know if that's
gonna be efficient for what meaning that
I think as AI gets more powerful and as
automation gets more powerful there's
probably gonna be ways to fuse with that
technology to make us potentially more
productive and efficient I'm not saying
this is gonna be a good thing I just
don't get if that's the goal it's just
gonna happen the best already happen to
the vescey outcome that the people in
power or cool worth or would be cool
sure and we know who's in power really
from the end of the day and what they're
into we're active willing to Wow
like why are they what what keeps us
around at that point oh oh I don't know
my I don't think well I just I'm really
really gonna pay for that fat guy at
Walmart they get melded with a computer
no I mean and that's part of why I think
you see the Gates being you know every
house is a fortress and they'll have
their own private security and I think
part of this is the long con of how
exactly do we let large sections of the
country fail do you think they hope for
how la like Colorado's coming back and
all of those you think that's I'm not
gonna go so far although I would and so
I'm gonna start going to as they're
doing on purpose but do you think
they're kind of actively hoping the
disease is spread I don't know what that
I said that this whole four ago say that
but I think they are making contingency
plans have been for a very long time to
just allow lard and listen Youngstown
Ohio Flint Michigan Detroit this is not
Bridgeport Connecticut none of this is a
speculator to be clear this is not about
reptilians control population this is
about
it's not about saying they're right but
about saying we know that there's a
certain lack of humanity in the ruling
class and at that point like why would
they keep around the poor this part why
you don't want this on society because
this is what it leads the reality is you
look at what's going on and you say that
these that you know they've already lat
cities Detroit did not have to fail
that's number well sure didn't actually
did not have to feel uh I think
globalization didn't have to go down the
way he was all of it didn't have to have
the point is that there's a certain
callousness that the ruling elites have
towards human beings it's just it's just
well I don't see now you also have tech
now the guys that are at the head of
these tech companies a lot and I've been
reading about them recently a lot of
them you know they're utopians they do
believe that they're making the world a
better place if who though well crap now
when you have those two things happen
when you have the callous cold-hearted
you know very pragmatic in a in a in a
in a you know sinister way elite have
all these tools and all this technology
you know what happens I think the only
thing that happens is they let large
sections of the country fail but and
most people will then at that point
flocked to cities for work and those
cities will become mega cities which is
why the Pentagon studies fighting what's
it gonna be like to fight urban warfare
in mega cities these are things at the
Pentagon studies sure cuz they assume
that by 2040 the populations of Los
Angeles in New York have grown
exponentially but like they're not
really you look at how New York is
growing quote-unquote it's growing with
these like massive towers for the rich
they're really not expanding we're like
I mean I guess the suburbs are more like
it's not just those kind of jobs in the
city they're being absorbed into the
city from Detroit from like it's more
like people those people also people are
just out of work or in fast food or 104
service I think what happens in what
they're imagining that will happen is
Detroit is not going to be a rarity it's
going to be one of many right and I'm
making
point that we don't I think she's having
super cities is seems like an optimistic
outcome compared to what we've seen no I
mean super cities I don't know you mean
I'm talking about you will have like
very crowded mhm
I mean similar to Asian cities with a
very crowded and and the majority but
why whose floor look lady boo Harvard
people who've been pushed out of their
work aren't gonna flock to New York or
like that's the last place you want but
that they're live in slums they'll live
in slums go go to Hong Kong they live in
slums to Mumbai they live in slums
I'm telling you did the sure future of
this is from the Pentagon this is not
from me this is from the / rabid Iraq no
I mean I'm telling you I'm telling you
I'm telling you there people are a goat
do you want to go to East New York and
you want to go to these places and you
want to see how the Brownsville so you
know that poor people live in New York I
don't understand what you're sayin but
building like mass migration horse they
they've been doing it for 200 years why
do you think that [ __ ] poor people
have becoming in New York City for ever
to work well immigrants come through New
York right part of it but you you've
you've all came through New York you
have all kinds of people that grew up in
horrible places that come to New York in
Rust Belt towns that are shot where do
you think they go down Ohio they come
here absolutely they're my guy they're
people that are here to be waiters I
don't I don't know what you're saying
New York is is a whole entire population
made of people that escaped from
somewhere
all right through me okay so if all of
those things if those areas continue to
not be able to support populations
they're gonna come here they're gonna go
to LA don't have a choice right but I'm
saying like a certain point it's just
the jobs will be filled well yeah okay
that was your argument you know the jobs
are filled now right they're gonna live
on the street okay
looma nahdi's like but how're where are
they gonna work they're gonna live in
tent cities they're gonna live in Hoover
okay but someone who's a super city's
amused me in cities about homeless super
cities like they're [ __ ] super you
[ __ ] [ __ ] by was entire term there
Angus it Easter go
- honk on these there are there's large
underclasses
in all of these city you just don't see
them they're in New York people just
don't see them they don't sure and and
they're going it's gonna be more and
more prevalent as time goes by I'm
telling you because also there's no
services that come here for government
services we have more services here
ok California has more certainly suppose
every one upstate they tried they will
continue to maybe try that was back but
still there are still more services here
than you're going to get in a rural part
of the country well they were just for
farming again you know we used to answer
those like it's you wonder like this
soil is gonna be poison it's also
Monsanto yeah the people people a lot of
them cannot farm they're like not
allowed to laws and regulations prevent
them from doing it and nobody has those
[ __ ] so we really get that was a
silly thing but it's like the weird
thing is you watch this will happen and
there's no reason why it has to it was
one point like we have resources though
well no we have reason why you'd be
clear because rich people want to take
everything yeah that's why it's
happening a lot you know
well they don't they're not content with
having a hundred million dollars they
want a hundred billion they're not
content with you know they were this is
the the the the level of consolidation
in these in these major industries like
media and finally I mean it's just wild
oh I mean where I can invested missed it
but trouble my clean this one I mean oh
yeah he's gonna he's gonna drain the
swamp none of it has to happen but all
that's going to happen well it's going
to happen for the same reason that like
you know your family you could get along
better with your family right but you
don't and it's your family sure so the
idea that a guy who's just been raised
you know completely wealthy is gonna
give a [ __ ] about somebody it's just not
gonna happen doesn't happen you know
it's just not gonna happen and and all
people can
we do at this point is get on a cab and
start flicking the bean
yeah and hope to God's work hope to god
that somebody's into that hope to god
that you're a fetish I would love to you
hopefully you're a fetish look you have
a big bigger following than we do yeah I
think we should start a website you need
your help maybe Ben could help with it
yeah I wanna be a cam girl I want you to
be a camera yeah because you listen
folks the way out is being a fetish
right the way out is gonna be a fad I'll
eat things that you tell me bang a
mukbang gonna roast a chicken in your
ass I'll wear a thong that's gonna be
the way out yeah that's gonna be the way
I suck all sorts of dildos you're gonna
have to do it all yeah you're gonna be
dressed up a Jeffrey star makeup I would
like to see you get I should make up
tutorial shoes you make up tutorial you
should get glamorous we should clap that
would be great when you come to LA maybe
we'll glam you up where you'll be a real
glamorous big glamour Pig
I mean gender is dead everything's it
doesn't matter who gives a [ __ ] when I
got in my pants it doesn't matter
nobody doesn't matter you're just gonna
be [ __ ] glam
I mean honestly sex seems passe to this
generation doesn't it yeah nobody's
[ __ ] no one seems to want to [ __ ]
nobody's [ __ ] and I get it cuz I like
[ __ ] back it awesome you know yeah
let's just [ __ ] get glamorous that's
what it is man people are coming in
different ways now yeah you know so much
of it is just you know performative
everything's performative you just want
other people to validate you sex is like
you know it's earthy it's it's it's like
older you stick something you knows you
start coming it's fine
yeah you just people want to be
glamorous yeah they just want to be you
know as sexual anymore it's just not for
mation
that lizard thing yeah it's just
affirmation yeah it's just that's nice
no it's tricking off that big ass I want
you to put your lights in the sky those
lights represent love they represent the
love that
want every inside of every single one of
you okay
and I just want you to I want you to
tell me one thing
I want you to tell me why a bunch of
Jewish art students were in the World
Trade Center
they were bomb technicians [ __ ] Mossad
they put bombs in those towers and they
fell
let's go why a man great cuz they gotta
be great thank you for listening
everybody please fold your complaints to
my agent manager I'm kidding where can
people find you find me on Twitter and
Instagram a trake umph on my twitter you
can you come podcast check that out it's
back now it's bad it's back so our love
is disgusting great new episodes of both
podcasts you can noise my patreon you
can find it on my Twitter my patreon
feed but yeah check me I got all
supposed to cut me and Lucy Steiner and
make Orlov is disgusting we're also
starting to make sketch videos there
gonna be a YouTube presence probably so
2020 is gonna be big for the company vs.
go subscribe to all that go subscribe to
my youtube channel the Tim Dillon show
that is the channel Tim Dillon show my
other channel I do nothing with Tim
Dillon's show on YouTube all our
sketches are podcasts are gonna be
reloaded when we take the ads out that
YouTube may or may not have a problem
with we don't want to channel take it
down so go subscribe to the channel
subscribe to me on Apple podcast please
also on Instagram Tim Jay Dylan D I ll
on Twitter Tim Jay Dylan Tim Dylan
comedy calm for all the dates we have
just announced Austin Texas I'm gonna be
there in January it's [ __ ] great I'm
really excited about that so if you are
in Texas I'm telling you right now don't
be stupid
[ __ ] go and come see me January 15th
through the 18th I'm gonna be cap city
absolutely cap city in Austin it's my
favorite clubs okay
also I'm gonna be in January I'm gonna
be at Magoo bees in Maryland right
outside of Baltimore Maryland I'm going
to be up in Toronto and at a great
theater I'm going to be at the house of
comedy in in Arizona I'm going to be in
Minneapolis at the same I mean you just
got to go Tim de la comédie calm all the
dates are there
grab the tickets we have links to all of
the places I'm going it's easy to
navigate and yeah like I said if you are
in a secret society or you were tapped
to be in wanting you didn't choose to be
in one very interesting or if you have a
friend that was in one DM me on
Instagram or DM me on Twitter and and
and again many of you will do this as a
prank but I don't care because I will
find the real one does it matter many of
you are gonna be like oh you fat I know
we had it it's a funny joke it's a funny
joke those guys aren't [ __ ] us whoa
don't let them [ __ ] us you're not
[ __ ] legit legit people that are in a
secret society that want to tell us how
it works and also want to sacrifice us
let us keep the conversation open yeah
let's keep it open I will I have an
agent manager I will put you in contact
with them if you want to sacrifice both
me and Rayman put her son spikes and
roast us like guinea pigs I just want to
feel something a hundred percent goodbye